[Music]
i just want our new place to look nice
in case someone brings home a lady
friend
relationship pressuring and yes i know
this is in the previously on and from a
different episode but the show decided
to include it here too so my hands are
tied
this episode within an episode made me
wonder what other toffin katara fanfic
was out there and boy oh boy
i think people may have forgotten that
this is a kids show
[Applause]
[Music]
synchronized grooming also katara
doesn't get her own bathroom or at the
very least her own time in the morning
to be in there alone
not to mention you've got momo off to
the side drinking what i can only assume
is warm pee
you've got a little dirt on your
everywhere actually
i'm tired of your anti-dirt bias cat in
the words of the ancestral poets of my
people
god made dirt and dirt don't hurt the
fancy lady
day spa sounds like my kind of place i
mean spas really should be everyone's
kind of place and not just fancy ladies
not sure if this sin is for the
gendering of pamper culture or that some
people think they're too good to give
their body some tlc but either way i
haven't had some mani petty goodness in
my life in months
that's definitely a sin having said that
doing it against their will is
also a sin so maybe cool it with the
forced foot filing wait they still let
toff continue her treatment after
this happened bossing say must have
figured out affordable insurance plans
quicker than the rest of the world
i think she looks cute like that time
you put a sweater on your pet poodle
monkey
these girls apparently went to the
stephen king school of bullying things
star setting aside my mixed feelings on
the shot and freud of revenge is earth
bending basically disintegration now
because that's a big hole and there is
zero debris showing i know it doesn't
matter but
[Music]
you're really pretty i mean you say it
doesn't matter but it's kind of the
whole point of your vignette isn't it
[Music]
the moon flower likes partial shade
maybe but i'm calling bullsh
that it would blossom back up this
quickly unless spyro is a flowerbender
honestly that makes sense with his
jasmine obsession
more flower bending
from the vine falling so slow
this kid is crying and iro is singing
and if i'm honest i'm not sure which i
want to stop more
also thinking you a stranger can make a
kid happy when the caretaker can't aka
not minding your own [ __ ] business
also also this kid has
tears streaming down his face in a giant
snot bubble that his caretaker never
actually takes care of you might think
that's okay but it's not
huge kids i'm mugging you with that
stance
uncle ira would be a master cenbender
with a solid stance
you are a much more serious threat of
all my favorite masterclass courses
ira's session on becoming a better
mugger is probably my favorite
happy birthday my son
[Music]
if only i could have helped you i would
have believed in you like the thief
protected you like the children
comforted you like the crier
and made sure your moon flowers were
always properly shaded
seriously though as convenient as all of
this happening on the same day is it
still gets me
if nothing else it's pretty cool that
this show takes the time to take
storytelling risks and do something
special so i'm crying uncle and offering
a sin off
apparently even bossing say has its
version of joe exotic and somewhere
netflix just green lit a tiger dillo
king documentary
night of the kangalepus
oh forget it i mean honestly did you
think we weren't going to take a sin off
for the greatest cabbage farmer in the
history of television here's your sin
off good sir
yeah that seems about right but you have
to open this gate
or what for that sure but how did this
zookeeper even know this zumanji parade
was coming in advance enough to get
ahead of it aang just improved this pied
piper routine like he was in a
christopher guest movie which would have
had to have been a mighty wind right
yay aang is leading the animals to the
glorious freedom of a different form of
captivity
also how are there already visitors
attending also also how will the zoo
even operate outside of the heavily
guarded city gates i really don't think
we've been to zoo here has thought this
one through
what's this does saka know how to think
things instead of actually saying them
there's no way she didn't hear his nosey
and noisy exclamation from this distance
chittering monkey in the spring he
climbs treetops
and thinks himself tall laugh if you
want but around eight mile in the b
these kind of haiku battles can
determine who rules the streets you
think you're so
smart with your fancy little words this
is not so hard
if you had one shot or one opportunity
would you capture it i'll paddle yours
too apparently the saka stands for
inciting others to
saka him in the face in fall the clean
plum drops
always to be squashed little known fact
in haiku teacher school they always
train you to carry plum up your sleeve
for just such occasions
you wouldn't think it would come in
handy that much but you'd be surprised
she's got a jar of mayo up her other
sleeve that you don't even want to know
what the situation that brings that into
play
uh that's one too many syllables there
bub
i'm just trying to think of how long
this haiku enforcer has been waiting to
do this most days he just sits in the
class debating to himself
whether chocolate has two syllables or
three and if there's more than one
syllable in the word fire
but today is finally his day uncle we
have a problem
hey iro had his own story he can't be in
this one too one vignette per character
them's the rules
excuse me sir would you and your
girlfriend care for dessert
she is not my girlfriend sure zuko
overreacts here but honestly this is on
the server that's like server 101
never assume anything you have
quite an appetite for a girl for a girl
close your eyes
and don't peek i mean this is stupid
enough as it is but this is a super
public place in full view of all sorts
of places people could be hiding our
boners is strong i guess which nation
was that again
i brought you something it's a coupon
for a free cup of tea do they wrap those
special ribbons around every single
coupon that seems like unnecessary
overhead
how was your night prince zuko tell me
more tell me more
momo could fly anywhere so why wouldn't
he find a nice forest lake or stream to
drink out of instead of an alley barrel
shouldn't those alley panthers be in eng
zoo right now we saw his whistle of
animal friendship blast through the
entire city
skeleton keys and then momo was so sad
that he fell asleep in the rain drowned
him in oppa's footprint and provided his
new panther friends with an afternoon
snack i mean
that is what this conclusion is
indicating right the show is dark yo
i could french manicure a chicken while
it was running away
people be like how is there a comment on
the video when it just posted fans be
like i'm a member motherfu
you can be a [ __ ] member too
get videos early extra videos bonus
podcasts
swag discounts and more click the
patreon link in the description or at
cinemasins.com to take your sin to the
next level
i can't believe we finally made it to
boston say in one piece
and you go in pieces [ __ ] wow
great makeup thanks for a clown
well i'm funny how i mean funny like i'm
a clown i am use you
doctors brought us into this world as
babies and doctors take good care of
your grandma
it is usually best to admit mistakes
when they occur
daniel sand you'll look revenge that way
start by digging to
on second thought you should probably
stick to saving people
that's a faint thing i have something
for you too
now it's your turn to close your eyes
hold it hold it is this a kissing book